our phone number is two one nine two
david p take a listen to this voicemail
that i received very interesting take on
the entire theme song stuff that we've
been talking about take a listen to this
David David I was just watching your
YouTube videos
did I miss something was there some
contest that I'd miss out on it I hope
it's not too late to enter but like what
do you think about this one okay I've
been working on for the last like whole
three minutes David Pakman the honest
Jews bringing you the news oh I think
that's free you don't even got to put my
name on it yeah I'm actually a little
bit worried about this is it why does it
why does it need to be qualified whether
a Jewish person is honest that's a
little weird but in any case we're
keeping the theme song we have we are
not accepting new submissions at this
time I I do appreciate it to the extent
that this was genuine we have a great
bonus show for you today
sign up at join pakman.com or at
patreon.com slash david pakman show both
will give you instant access to the
bonus show many important stories to be
discussed there today